hi there stay here today I'm going to
introduce the discussion that I had with
Daniel Candido of Brazil who was the
winner of the contest we had where
people had to submit you know question
what they would like to ask Steve if
they had a 30 minute chance to speak you
know with me and I stress the spot and I
was learning our language what we did is
we did the 30 minute audio discussion
which is available at my blog and I'll
put a link here in the description box
and we had a sort of ten minute video
discussion which you are going to see in
a few in a few minutes here Daniel lives
I don't know the geography of Brazil
very well he lives in the interior Minas
Gerais is a very important province in
Brazil he lives near the city of Belo
Horizonte here you'll hear this in the
interview he's been coming like everyone
in Brazil he had English at school but
didn't learn very much but for the last
eight months he has applied himself to
sort of an predominantly an input based
method of learning he also discovered my
role I think his name is Vergara who is
a Brazilian that I knew and we've
communicated and we share the same views
on input based learning so Danielle
followed these methods and I must say
has done a tremendous job his English in
eight months is improved tremendously
and well I don't want to let you know
too much about what we discuss but it's
just I just want to stress again that
focusing on input focusing on
comprehension on listening and reading
all the things that you can easily
organize whether you live in Brazil or
in China or in Russia or in Japan or
wherever you live you can do these
things and learn the language whatever
the language learn so much about the
language and slowly more of the language
becomes clearer to you it's a bit like
these it's something I might get into in
another video you know they have these
woodblock printing this woodblock
technique in Japan called Nitschke a
word you know there are different colors
and with each layer so they'll carve up
you know the wooden block and it'll be
one color and so they snap that and then
there'll be another set of features that
will have a different color and so we
get layer and layer and layer and with
each of these layers different features
appear and I think language her knees a
bit like that there's so many things
that you don't notice and then once
you've notice these things then some
other things start to appear and some
other things and all of this happens
through this process of input based
learning eventually of course you have
to activate by speaking and here again
you'll see that Daniel does a really
good job so without any further ado as
we say here is the discussion that I had
with Daniel bye for now
hi Daniel alright doing fine thank you
how are you I'm great
okay listen you're in Brazil
yeah I'm Raziel yes I mean Tanana is
closed and yeah how many people live in
your town I see I think I don't want and
sick sick thing new people yeah yeah hi
I'm sorry mission about an eighth mother
8 months actually accidentally collect
every person in Brazil next very stark
mean I have to pardon my English the
first part I study I guess exactly we're
liking 5th grade and high school
something like that
where do they say quarter small aku aku
no in the beauty and we're in this left
and a
I don't know nine months I student I
think that the best method that are used
the method do you friend my ver and and
I don't know one multiple I starting
going my practice because and my goal
equals only understand first and after
that I write I can price speaking
because I think if you if you understand
that people tell you more far more
likely do you use the link because you
absorb the link you you let's post the
link you will take that people say and
suddenly you able to understand able to
communicate with you and I've studied
quite a few languages and first of all
you for eight or nine months your
English is very very good for example
I'm always impressed with some of the
phrases you used like far more likely so
that's a very native like except
rephrase but so you're picking up these
phrases from your listening and reading
so that's point number one you're doing
very well
point number two when you learn based on
the input you just continue to improve
you just can sew it in another eight
months when you will have a listen to
much more read much more you know your
English will just be that much better
now obviously when you go to speak you
sometimes make mistakes but your
eventually make fewer mistakes you know
so I think you're on the right path I'm
very impressed
yeah right here yeah yeah and and I
think too as if one gets engaged in
listening and reading which I have done
for my Portuguese as well then we find
things that interest us so at some point
we're no longer just trying to learn the
language we're in fact learning other
things through the language you know
when I listen to those podcasts from
that radio station in some
I'm learning about life in Brazil I'm
learning about some of the issues were
still sorry I learn we learn more than
just a language but as we learn these
other things our language improves right
so I have some question about learn the
language and I think it's good for me
but good question because I don't know
it some people who watch the beating
YouTube something they walk me to Z and
you know a block and so the first of all
you speak and more than sexy manga but
what was the first one you're like and
why okay so the first one was French and
it's a bit like maybe in Brazil people
are in English at school and they don't
learn English so in Canada
we learn French at school and we don't
learn French so at some point well in my
case when I was 16 I got very interested
in French civilization civilization
French movies French everything so I
just got very interested and then I
ended up going to France I spent three
years in France so it's just a matter of
being turned on at some point you know
so that was the first one yeah
the second one was Chinese because I was
working for the Canadian government and
I was sent to Hong Kong to learn Chinese
that was my job but once you get started
like with the Chinese at first I'd watch
I knees very different but once you get
started then you get more and more
interested yes it is more turning or not
you know every language is difficult in
different ways with Chinese the biggest
difficulty is the characters because
that's just a lot of work you have to I
mean you have to learn all these
characters that's just everyday you have
to put in the time and the tones which
creates a bit of a problem both in
comprehension and in in pronunciation
because each sound can have four
different tones but the grammar is very
easy
there's no subjunctive and tenses don't
change I go today I go tomorrow we go
you go they go everything nothing
changes it's it's a very the grammar is
very easy so yeah it's difficult but you
know it all comes down to your
motivation yeah yeah like me and you
using the matter input but how did you
get this method you know what I just
realized
so it's funny I never talked about it in
terms of an input based learning I
hadn't read crashing I hadn't even met
my yo you know however if I think back
when I learned French all my learning in
the classroom you know I could still
only just kind of put words together
even though they focused on grammar
I really couldn't use the grammar then I
got so interested in French that I
watched movies and I tried to meet
people and so it really was through
input and I started reading the same
with Chinese I learned Chinese in one
year I was a diplomat so there were
other diplomatic students they took two
years I learned better in one year than
they learned in two years and the reason
is that I read so much more than they
did I listened to so much more than they
did I went and everywhere I could find
stuff I was reading and listening so I
just noticed when I went to learn German
I did the same it's it's just it seemed
to me the natural way to learn is to
expose the brain to so much of the
language the brain starts to find
patterns the brain starts to ask
questions and then if I consult a
grammar about something that I'm curious
about
then I can understand it whereas the
traditional math
is to try to explain things to you and
now we're gonna drill you and you're
gonna quiz you and I personally I resist
I resist that so it's just something
that naturally developed and then you
know in the last ten years I've
discovered that there there are people
like a Geo viral
stephen krashen and others well who
pushed the idea of input based learning
and info based learning has the
tremendous advantage that it's easy to
organize you don't have to hire a doctor
you don't to find some guy talk to in
your town you don't have English
speakers so I saw it's it's just a yeah
it works yeah yeah you think you have
gift falling or you think and everyone
can learn oh oh something all people
have to have gift program because I have
a friend and and he said European and if
you don't have a gift you don't can
learn another language let's put it this
way I think some people are better than
others at learning languages probably
for a variety of reasons for example I
speak a lot of languages so I think
that's easier for me to learn a new
limit so but if someone else who only
speaks one language learns a second
language and then the third language and
a fourth language they will also become
better at learning languages but I think
the question is not important because
everyone can learn yeah so if some
people maybe some people can pronounce
better or some people are better at
remembering words and phrases like I
find that your ability to pick up on
these phrases is very good if I speak to
someone
most people have studied for eight
months are not gonna use some of the
phrases that I've heard you use in our
conversation so for whatever reason
you're picking up on these
maybe it's the way you're learning maybe
it's whatever there will be differences
between people but it doesn't matter
everyone can learn yeah so it doesn't
matter that that person B will be better
than you
person C won't be as good as you I don't
see why that is an important question
everybody can learn so I might do better
some might do worse everyone can learn
yes my yeah so I think talking to my
question I ain't your conversation and
thank you very much for your time I wish
you lots of luck and maybe we can have
another conversation in eight months
[Music]